along with heavenly halo Salam alaykum
assalamu alaikum how you guys doing I'm
here with formerly juice a balloon or
right so your your originally you're
from are you from Spain yes I am from
Majorca Iceland Majorca Iceland in in
Spain that's in Spain in Spain yes how
far weren't Valencia la balle article
seasons so you used to be a opera singer
yes yes some some years before some
years before yes yeah and then how did
you or why did you accept Islam how did
you come to the point
yeah because I ever have ever searched
by anyways from I think from 1618 years
we have in any any kind of philosophies
or activities spiritually you know I
don't know
sorry but my English is not very good
and familiar that at 40 years I find a
man speaking about spiritualities and
metaphysics yes no but he he always
talked with very very deep sentences
very very clear sentences and I ever
ever asked it
what what's the what's the book here no
because I read I read a lot of books in
spirituality and metaphysics you want to
see what's his source what he's quoting
from you want to see you're asking what
book is because he's reciting somebody I
asked I asked me where where is the the
well he he read this oh I see because
the here his character his his words and
and and all there are something deep
there no Sukhdeep means and he never he
never took me he he was Muslim no so he
never Nev never speaks about Islam never
about a year or something
and I I asked I asked after after a year
to speaking about metaphysics or
something I asked I asked him well what
do you whether you read these things no
because I am very very and he says no no
I take this from Quran just just from
the Quran also now he's telling you did
this what he's talking about these this
is from the Quran yes yeah I asked well
where you read this all these things yes
pick with me and that this book was was
the Quran yes so what happened next and
the next
I I have a crack in my mind no because
my concept of of Islam is just a Tuareg
zonda and in right on the desert Europe
in the desert my day off of Islam there
not nothing of religions yeah
there are sect in in in Arabia somewhere
the desert yeah but he says no Quran is
is the the last the last miss message
like the New Testament the last system
it has old nudist - the last the final
Testament and sent to men all of mankind
the Quran the religion we say the
verbatim word of God Almighty Allah
deals yeah yeah yeah of course yeah and
they returned at home is spoken with my
wife and it says look just
and this Abdullah is the name this this
brother it says this and we to speaking
about this and just just week later
later we embrace Islam you and who who's
we
you and your why Allah together you and
your wife yeah you both so you're his
wife both for you after meeting Abdullah
right yes after meeting this Muslim and
him reciting some book to you reciting
and you're hearing these these words
from it now you ask them which book is
this it's the Quran so now you start to
look into it you talk to your wife and
now you both accept Islam yeah yeah
because it was very it was very crazy
very very crack I don't know how what
what were what was from what you
remember how long has it been now since
you became Muslim 20 years ago 20 years
ago 20 so how long were you opera singer
how long were you doing the opera
singing I really a Sangha Buckley your
life in [ __ ] song yeah after in in a car
yeah in a car can we hear something from
you you have something just so people
can see like your how just something
just very short and then a little bit
yeah how about I heard now can you can
you do that a diner pardon
can you do that I die now yeah I heard
you call the night I I think
this this hobby I have with with with
with the music yeah I just educated this
No yeah now I don't want to sing all
yeah
because Islam teach not all is valid
valid oh yes valid yeah well it not
always valid yeah
and the the sensation that when when I
sing event for example or some other
[ __ ] for example all is good inside it's
all good yeah yeah this is it's very
calming for me yeah no can we hear can
we hear your Adams Alabama there that
yes make it with harmonies of
Mediterranean military and harmony yeah
Abajo
[Applause]
hi
[Applause]
whoa whoa whoa whoa
Oh
Oh mashallah this is beautiful for the
not yet Muslims for people who don't
want noticed the this is the call to
prayer so he was saying God is greater
God is the greatest
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator God Almighty Allah
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator God Almighty Allah and
Muhammad is the messenger come to prayer
come to prayer come to success come to
success I mean this is such a beautiful
not only the the melody of itself but
then the words the meaning is even it's
much more powerful this is so so deep I
mean in closing tell us now so what from
there one week later did you say you
accepted Islam after were you and your
wife yes how is it I mean many people
they come in Islam and it's a struggle
I mean how has it been for you with your
family with your friends after you
accepted Islam and how did you get
through these struggles well every when
you make a change like this in in a
Catholic Territory no please it's not
not a very easy very easy not so big
because the people hate you or something
but to to crush the to crush the ideas
of the norm from the norm the community
no is ever challenging right oh okay
and and of course ever ever have people
people it says well okay okay you're
you're Muslim you're Muslim okey but but
do you pray I said of course
if I changed to his language is for
something yeah somebody it it cleans
your mind or something and and I say no
I am the same person but I find I found
the the thing is searched yeah yeah I
like to answer say yeah I pray but I
don't pray I pray the way Jesus prayed
right he fell on his face and prayed I
just adjusted my prayer to pray directly
to God
I don't pray to anyone in creation but
to the crater that's that's the natural
way I mean this is what people when they
hear about this the pure monotheism
Islam you say tawheed people connect
with this right there but so simple that
it's very strange
Wow in power because it's simple yeah
it's that simple but yet so powerful we
imagine that if you want something
really really hard you must do - you
must like Indiana Jones no to pass a lot
of a lot of tests if you want to find
the book book you must to search it and
you must still yeah Tigers and you can't
you can't understand that it's very
simple like this yes to recognize the
recognize the the voice of Allah no just
just to recognize this so recognize the
what the the signs of Allah through the
Quran through the Quran and final what
helped you to get through finally how
now you stuck in there you didn't give
up what helps you to get through these
struggles this is a
a level of English no worries no worries
what advice do you have for people other
Spanish people who they are out there
but there again their vision of Islam is
clouded by must much of the
misrepresentation of Islam by much of
the propaganda that's out there what
advice do you have for people they like
what we have to say you know the worship
of the Creator the one God alone at his
creation you know being an upright human
being doing good deeds living a good
host of life but now there's a lot of
these misconceptions almost as a terror
is this that and the other all this
nonsense what advice do you have from
them I just I just say to all the people
who asks me I just searched and if I
found and searched that I found and
nothing more because the only problem I
think of the people is to cut to cut
with with with the past and and to undo
and to catch the new the new idea no to
to crash with your community because
[Music]
from from this moment from this moment
you are different from this moment yeah
yes we're gonna make it even easier now
in Spanish what advice do you have for
those people considering or looking for
purpose of life and now they can benefit
for some of your words
all right of the gems that you have to
say you what you went to but now we'll
make it easy for you well you can tell
them in Spanish in Spanish yes go ahead
and give the message to the Spanish
people to the Spanish people yes in
Spanish it was literally a literally a
theorem cambio in to into universal
spiritual and to concepción de la
spiritually de una cosa que es lo que
sólo puede sentir not a lo pueden
communica for que sólo el corazon P de
sólo el corazon P the SI cambio Sinuessa
c siempre se quiere Mo's con los mismos
Eskimos piensa que cuando una persona
busca la verdad
busca el libro de instrucciones mm die
welcome o se llama the wall Casa de Jose
Koran Ching Chang de la misma no
importantes que tu recognizes an s o la
verdad que busca es was lo que es was
looking integral sisters no kts a
complete o e Feliz thank you so much it
was a an honor meeting you I really
appreciate you sharing that with us
and I hope you guys enjoyed this short
little segment were in Spain Valencia
and for a person who's really
intelligent and they see that everything
has an expiration date the milk in your
fridge the foods and the cupboards your
ID card you got to renew but you cannot
renew life when it's over it's done so
intelligent person thinks Ponder's and
knows that death is coming and we better
get serious we want to know why we're
here where we're going and you can see
another person who found purpose found
the purpose of life read the Quran look
into it
don't be blinded what other people say
come to the source come to the Muslims
connect and hopefully you also will
learn grow and develop something that
brings peace and contentment happiness
into one's life and gives you the tools
for life I hope to see you again here
next time on the Deen show and continue
to tune in Salaam alaikum peace be with
you